الاكبر من نوعه في العالم تكريم منتظر
لصوت الارض طلال مداح
وتخبطات وماسك مستمره وخاصيه المشاهدات
موضع جبل اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
صاحب الحنجره الذهبيه عملاق الاغنيه
السعوديه فيلسوف النغم الاصيل وصوت الارض
كلها القاب اطلقت على شخص واحد رمز فني
كبير في العالم العربي وهو الفنان والملحن
السعودي الكبير طلال مداح اللي طغى اسمه
من امس على هاشتاجات مختلفه في تويتر منها
طلال مداح وليلى طلال مداح وكلنا بنكرم
صوت الارض من بعد طبعا ما اعلن رئيس هيئه
الترفيه في السعوديه المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ عبر تغريده عن طلبه من عائله الفنان
الراحل الاتفاق على ليله تكريم كبيره لصوت
الارض تليق بطلال مداح رحمه الله عليه
وكان رد ابن الراحل عبد الله طلال مداح
على رساله المستشار بعدم وجود اي مانع من
اقامه حفل تكريم لوالده ووجه السكر طبعا
لي المستشار تركي ال الشيخ على هذه
المباراه
في القلب لسه
هواها ظالم ولكن
في القلب لسه هواه ان قلت بكره يحن فديت
[موسيقى]
في جن
ون ونساني
[موسيقى]
وما في دقايق مشاهدينا من بعد الاعلان الا
واسم الفنان الراحل صار ترند على تويتر
ليعلن المستشار تركي ال الشيخ في تغريده
الثانيه انه اي فنان يشارك في ليله تكريم
صوت الارض يعتبر تكريم له شخصيا وانه
الدعوه مفتوحه لكل نجوم الخليج والعالم
العربي وبالفعل التفاعل على الاعلان كان
كبير جدا رغم مرور تخيلوا 22 عام على رحيل
الفنان الكبير لكن التفاعل اللي صار
بيخليك تحس بالعظمه والقيمه الفنيه
الكبيره الرمز فني كبير مثل طلال مداح
اكثر من 30 فنان وفنانه من السعوديه
والخليج والعالم العربي اتسابقوا ولا
اعلان مشاركتهم في ليله تكريم الراحل اللي
يتوقع ان تكون الاضخم عالميا
[موسيقى]
هو في شيء مشاهدينا كان لافت بين تغريدات
غير التفاعل الكبير على تغريده دعوه
المستشار تركي ال الشيخ واللي هو التوقعات
الفنانين والناس لليله حفل تكريم الفنان
الراحل طلال مداح خلينا نشوف
[موسيقى]
وعلى فكره ده عود رئيس الهيئه العامه
للترفيه مختصره على الفنانين بس لا هو
كمان اعلن في تغريده عن دعوه لجماهير
الانديه الرياضيه السعوديه اللي يغني لهم
الفنان الراحل وكان من الداعمين لهذه
الانديه وللمنتخب السعودي
[موسيقى]
منصور يا اغلى شعار يا سعودي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
طبعا هذا تكريم المرتقى مشاهدينا معنا
الان من الرياضه الناقد الفني يحيى زريقان
اهلا بك استاذ يحيى معنا استاذ يحيى يعني
تكريم هائل قامه فنيه ضخمه وهائلات برايك
ليش كل هذا الزخم الكبير من قبل الفنانين
كثر يعني متوقع انه يكون هذا تكريم الاضخم
عالميه فكل هذا الزخم رغم انه الفنان
الراحل يعني توفي من اكثر من 22 عام
[موسيقى]
مرحبا راويه
اولا
يقولون عندنا في الامثال الشعبيه ما يعطي
السيل الا من كبره
كنت اتوقع في كل لحظه وحين ان يفاجئنا
وزير الترفيه تركي ال الشيخ
بالحدث الذي يعتبر علامه مسجله
ويحدث الفارق في كافه
المواسم الترفيهيه التي عشناها حتى الان
وبالتاكيد
ان
ردود الافعال
والصدى الكبير الذي تركه
وزير الترفيه عندما اعلن عن تكريمه للفنان
طلال مداح
ليس مجرد صوت فقط
وله مطرب حي الله
طلال درب وبشر بيوت طلال نسيج اجتماعي
كامل طلال مكون ثقافي وفني نجح
طوال مشواره في التعريف بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه على كافه الصعود والمستويات
ولذلك دائما طلال يحدث الفارق في اي حدث
ولذلك سيكون هذا المهرجان مهرجان التكريم
هو العلامه الفارغه في مسيره هيئه الترفيه
من خلال ما تقدمه من فعاليات واي شطاح حتى
يومنا هذا
التكوين الاثر الاثر الذي تركه اعلان وزير
الترفيه بتكريم طلال مداح هو انعكاس حقيقي
لذلك
الاثر الذي تركه لنا طلال مداح في حياتنا
الاجتماعيه عاطف على ريادته كونه قد سجل
اول تحول في الذائقه لدى الشارع السعودي
ناهيك عن تحقيقه للقفزات الموسيقيه عبر
اللحم والاداء على مدى سنوات طويله نجح من
خلالها في مصر في طريق الاغنيه السعوديه
بالجمال والنور همم هو همم ايضا ربما من
اكثر الاشياء اللافته همم هو انه يعني
الفنان الراحل كان همم يعني بمثابه ذاكره
للاجيال اجيال متعدده ليس فقط سعوديه ولكن
كمان عربيه وعابر للزمن لدرجه انه حتى
اجيال لم تعاصره نهائيا من فنانين ومن
مستمعين ومتذوقين لفنه الجميل في ايامنا
هذه يعني شباب بالعشرين واصغر من هيك وما
زالوا يتذوقون هذا الفن الاصيل يعني
الفنان طلال مداح نموذج حقيقي بما يجب ان
يكون عليه الفنان من سلوك من تفاعل من
عطاء فما بالك الى ااا قلنا ان التاريخ
يسجل لطلال انه مؤسس الاغنيه السعوديه
الحديثه
عطفا على تلك القفزات التي احدثتها في
الموسيقى والغناء
انت ذكرت بانه يعني هو كان ايضا نقطه تحول
في الاغنيه السعوديه حتى وصلت الى ما هي
عليه الان خلينا نفهم اكثر كيف يعني من
ناحيه فنيه همم حدثنا بتفاصيل اكثر
طلال مداح نقطه تحول في ذائقه الشعب
السعودي نعم هذه حقيقه تاريخيه قبل ظهور
طلال مداح كان الشارع السعودي يتحفظ على
تعاطي ثقافه الغناء كنعرفه ومحتوى بظهور
طلال مداح في المشهد الفني السعودي اقبل
المجتمع السعودي على تعاطي هذا النوع من
المعرفه
والاعتزاز به وتكريسه نظرا لكون طلال
واحدا من ابناء هذا المجتمع
عاش همومهم والامهم وقدمها في اغنياته وفي
الحاني وكان يعبر عما يجول في خواطرهم من
امال واحلام وهموم الى اخره وقد
يعني يعني طلال حصل ايه
الاجماع من الشارع المحلي والاقليمي
والعربي على كفاءته الفنيه اولا
وثانيا على
نجوميته في الخلق
وثا وليس اخيرا هناك تاكيد على ان طلال
مداح هو العلامه الفارقه في الخطاب الفني
السعودي كونه اول من قدم لنا اغنيه سعوديه
متطوره تتكون من مذهب واثنين كوبليه
وخاض تجارب همم التاليف الموسيقي واقدم
حسيله جيده همم اثر كثيرا في مجال همم
المسرح الكتابه الفنيه شعر الالحان اخذ
بيد كثير من الملحنين من المؤدين
ساهم كثيرا في ان يتحلى قطاع الموسيقى
والفنون في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالايجابيه وبالحضور المشرف اجتماعيا
ورسميا وشعبيا هذا هو طلب مرتاح قبل ما
ننهي بدقيقه كيف تتوقع راح يكون هذا
التكريم الضخم اللي ممكن يكون بالفعل
الاضخم عالميا
دائما طلال
يخالف كل التوقعات ولكني ازعم ان هذا
الكرنفال الذي سيتحقق قريبا ااا لمريديه
ومحبيه ومحبي الغناء السعودي في العالم
العربي ومحميه طلال مداح كذلك كونه احد
اهرامات الغناء العربيه سيكون حدثا فارغا
ربما يتفوق او يتجاوز تصوراتنا لو اردنا
ان نتخيل هذا الحدث لكني اجزم انه سيكون
الحدث البارز في مسيره هيئه الترفيه
السعوديه شكرا جزيلا لك الناقد الفني يحيى
زريقان كان معنا من الرياض شكرا
التحياتي
[موسيقى]
الايام اللي احنا فيها مشاهدينا عم تشهد
احتفالات العالم في اعياد الميلاد وان شاء
الله ينعاد على الجميع بالخير والسعاده يا
رب على الرغم من مرض السرطان اللي بيعاني
منه لاعب كره القدم البرازيلي الاسطوره
من الاجتماع والاحتفال بعيد الميلاد على
طريقتهم في مستشفى
باولو واللي بيتعالج فيها نجم كره القدم
البرازيلي البالغ من العمر 82 عام واللي
دخل المستشفى من نهايه فبراير كانت في
ليله نشرت صوره للعائله من غرفه المستشفى
عنوانتها بانه كل العائله تقريبا موجوده
في المستشفى الامتنان والحب والاتحاد
والاسره هو جوهر عيد الميلاد وانتشر فيديو
على تويتر لابنتي ليله عيد الميلاد وبيظهر
بالفيديو الاسطوره الرياضيه بيليه ولكن في
حاله محزنه للاسف
الو
سلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
للاسف دخل المرحله
الاسطوره البرازيلي بيعاني من سرطان
القولون وفشل كلوي ومشاكل في القلب كمان
وكل العالم بانتظار اخبار عن صحته
وتطورتها
[موسيقى]
نيجي الان لا مالك وسيد تويتر الجديد الى
المصري ما زال ماضي في رحلته واخباره
ليبدو انها ما راح تنتهي والرحله اكيد
بتعرفوا عنوانها تويتر في اكتوبر اعلنت
تويتر
على احد المتابعين اللي سالوا عن الميزات
والتصميم الجديد فقال لهم ماسك سنقوم
بترتيب الشماليات ونضيف اعدادات لايقافها
واعتقد ان الجميع سيحبها يعني بالخط
العريض تويتر رح يعدل ميزات عدد المشاهدات
اللي اطلقها مؤخرا وراح يسمح للمستخدمين
بايقاف تشغيلها اذا حبوناهم يعملوا هيك
وماسك العاده ما بيفوتوا اي تقرير اعلامي
عن تويتر وجاهز فورا للرد عليه فمن يومين
نشرت رويترز انه ازال ميزات بتساعد على
منع الانتحار والميز المشاهدين اسمها دير
از هاوس وعم نعرض لكم عينات منها وبتظهر
فقط في حال البحث عن كلمات بتدل على شيء
معين مثل كورونا او نقص المناعه كوارث
طبيعيه والعنف او غيرها من الكلمات
وخلالها بيظهرت تويتر الدعم او بيظهر
تويتر الدعم للشخص وبتكون المميزه بمثابه
من نوع من انتحار والوقوف الى جانبه لكن
فهاد المعلومات المتداوله بهذا الخصوص ورد
على التقرير اللي نشرته بانه خطا والميزه
بعدها موجوده ومان لغت ابدا زي ما قال
يعني اخبار ومعلومات وروايات وسياسات
جديده وتطورات عم نشهدها يوميا حول ماسك
وتويتر ومن بين الاخبار والفوضى اللي
شفناها وشهدناها في في شيء ايجابي نشره له
ماسك فقال صحيح انه تويتر مش امن كفايه
لكنه ليس في طريق سريع للافلاس ولا يزال
هناك الكثير من العمل للقيام فيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام حلقه تفاعلكم لهذا
اليوم نترككم على محاك من تاريخ الفنان
الكبير طلال مداح الله يرحمه الى اللقاء
مق
ادير يا قلب
العناء مقادي
[موسيقى]
مق
ادير
واستن بي انا مق
[موسيقى]
ادير مقادير يا قلب العناء مقادير وش ذنبي
انا مقادير يا قلب العالم
[موسيقى]
مشاوير واتمنى لهنا مقادير مقادير
يا عمري الحزن والشكوى يا خطوه
على الخطوه على همي سنين
يا عمري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يا ليله دانه
[موسيقى]
بلسانه
انسان
نعيمه الحب
وشوق قلبي على يدي وهو اغلى ما عندي شوق
اللي عليا اوه اغلى ما عندي وتبقى زياده
في حبك اجمل من قلبي
[موسيقى]